please welcome our dear friend carla
[Applause]
sometimes i think to myself like you and
i weren't meant to be together because
we're so enthusiastic and similar oh i
know totally and i said if anybody can
play with me it's you
you raise your energy i raise my energy
it's like
i just feel less alone on this planet
when i'm with you i'm like oh carla gets
it and i'm really excited about today's
dish tell us all about it yes so we're
gonna do a white bean soup with a
coconut oil and it is like it's oh
so we have the beans and they've been
cooking for about 40 minutes and it's
just water water and beans and then
we're going to add in the onions which
are already cut here okay
and then we're going to add some
slivered garlic now i would like to
introduce two very special guests that
we have joining us here is cbs 2 new
york anchor steve obermeyer
i'm so happy to see you in person
because well you're always on my tv at
home
it's a little surreal to break that wall
down hi steve wow welcome here i'm very
happy to see you so great
thank you
um
so
also brought another marathoner to mom
please introduce us back in 1977 this
man set the guinness world record
running from new york to san francisco
in 53 days he is a legend in the ultra
marathon community and now at the age of
71 he's going to be running another 100
mile race before the new york city
marathon for the tunnel to towers
foundation for the families of 911
[Applause]
okay carla i want to make sure we're
putting everything in properly okay now
so we have the onions and the garlic in
here and then we're gonna add all these
like little business things we've got
some
celery seeds we have some
chili flakes we've got this smoked salt
we're going to add that in there okay
and then we're going to just press we're
going to actually we have our little
immersion blender hold on
i love an immersion blender i really do
it's um a really good piece to invest in
in your kitchen
you're gonna have some chunks of beans
okay that's a that's another hot tip
because we don't want baby food right oh
my gosh i get it now
tom what do you normally eat before a
marathon well
i'm kind of the old school i stick to
bad butter and jam mostly for me and a
little bit of chocolate and then let me
ask you a question have you ever
finished a marathon
and just
what is the treat that you give yourself
oh
butter chocolate
[Applause]
you are also a marathon runner i ran a
marathon yes
when was that and how was that it was in
1940
i mean i'm
sorry i was born in 1964. um it was i
was 40 years old
and um i ran it in uh
four hours in one minute
[Applause]
so tom when you saw like forrest gump
what
were you like yeah uh-huh well he he
copied me and he didn't ask permission
[Applause]
where's mine by the way um i i am loving
this i am so happy should i put a little
olive oil on top um steve and tom what
have you tried your soup yet
not yet we haven't been given the
clearance yet are you ready to go okay
oh yeah are you gonna eat those
peppercorns like that sometimes what i
do with peppercorns also like i just
normally how about that like i'll just
do a um
[Applause]
everywhere carla i like that also we
went with the big spoon
yeah i love you so much it's about
taking a big bite out of life that's
right
can i tell you about this cornbread that
they also have oh my god why am i not
eating your cornbread
yeah so we have this cornbread because
my my cookbook my um children's book is
carl and the christmas cornbread and so
it happens to be gluten-free but it's
full of fat because you'll love it
before then oh my god yeah and then we
make a cinnamon butter
right
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's butter softened
cinnamon
almond extract and a little bit of salt
so tom
you have a movie that just came out on
friday will you tell us about it
yeah it's the story of uh basically of
my life the ups and downs of my life
i uh
was a runner and then
i developed into an alcoholic i went
there in the past where i went into the
hospital and the doctors told me
on no uncertain terms that i had a week
to 10 days to live and if i don't change
right now right here and then
i would die
so i promised god
i promised my wife and daughter that if
i got out of that hospital i would run
and ever since that i've run thousands
and thousands and thousands of miles to
help people in need especially those
that tend to abuse alcohol but putting
it on the big screen i hope i will help
somebody somewhere i'm sure that you
will tom and thank you so much for
sharing that with us the name of it is
saved by my people saved by my feet and
we'll have that
up on the website
thank you and steve i'm so happy to meet
you in person and maybe do this again
together i would love that please
especially if there's going to be food
here for me you're going to have me here
okay everybody thank you steve obermeyer
and tom mcgrath carla hall is going to
stick around and after the break we're
going to answer all of your turkey
questions ahead of thanksgiving gobble
gobble turkey hotline
[Applause]
[Music]
you